[Musique]
les pièces de la paix 02 100 par exemple
réalisé en ce moment dans l'atelier
derrière nous
vous êtes ici au contrôle de qualité
qu'est ce qu'on y fait on fait le
contrôle de toutes les pièces qui sont
montés sur la voiture c'est à dire ça va
de la petite rondelle en passant par les
boîtes de vitesses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
appartement on n'a pas de sécurité à
tous les niveaux
il n'est pas question
défendre - touristes qu'ils soient
financiers qui soient morales
soit
la toul et à tous les niveaux l'arrivée
des grands constructeurs one en étant
fait que les moyens sont complètement
disproportionnées c'est devenu un
championnat devançant sculpteur pour
trouver des financements des dépenses
c'est aussi beaucoup plus difficile la
situation économique n'aide pas le fait
qu'ils aient eu pas mal de fusions
acquisitions dans les années passées
n'ont plus montré diminue le nom
[Musique]
ça commence avec des lots
comme des éléments de carrosserie qui
sont plutôt des souvenirs pour des
amateurs ou des passionnés de la formule
1 et 2 de l'écurie prost donc c'est des
éléments qui feront 500 euros enfin
entre 100 et 500 euros tout le monde
pourra avec trouver une pièce un aileron
un triangle un élément personnel et
personnalisé proches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]